- All right everybody
let's finish up this hour,
with something positive and inspiring.
This is what I'm liking.
So street wear has become a
force in the fashion industry,
with billions spent on
the latest sneaker trends.
But many believe that
there's a lack of plus size
representation in that market.
And that's where Essie
from New York comes in.
She co-founded a community
called Thick Laces.
Which promotes street wear
among plus size women.
Everybody say hi to Essie.
(audience cheers)
- [Kelly] Hi Essie.
So how did you come up with this idea?
- So I've always been a
huge fan of street wear
and sneakers and things like that.
And like everyone else
during the pandemic,
other people picked up
baking banana bread.
I picked up buying tons of sneakers.
(Kelly laughs)
And so I was using hashtags,
and tagging these brands
that had the sneakers.
And I was realizing,
not only were they not featuring
women who look like me,
but they weren't featuring
any plus size women.
And so I reached out to my best friend,
Katie who's the co-founder of Thick Laces.
And I said,
" Hey, we need to start
a community of our own.
Because I see my timeline.
I see women all the time who are plus size
and they are killing it and
they deserve to be seen."
And so we started Thick Laces.
And it has quickly grown,
into something bigger
than we ever imagined.
We got the chance to work with Reebok.
We've worked with New Balance,
and Nike,
and eBay.
And it's a community,
that's really making a
change within the street wear
and sneaker community.
So I'm so excited to continue the work.
- Well, what's incredible about this,
is this isn't your first time to create
an online community, right?
- It is not.
I believe that representation
is super important.
I grew up in the foster care system.
And was later adopted
by a wonderful family.
But in my younger years,
being in the foster care system,
and also being plus size,
I never felt like I fit in.
And so that's something
that stuck with me,
until I moved to New York City
to pursue a career in
fashion and modeling.
And I was wearing these crop tops
and bright colors and all
these different things.
And there were so many
plus size women saying,
"I wish I could wear that."
And so I started the
hashtag golden confidence,
as a way for other women to use it
outside of myself,
to see like I'm wearing it.
They're wearing it.
They're doing these things.
And you are just as
beautiful as anybody else.
- Oh my God.
(audience claps)
Well, congratulations on all the success.
I'm liking your right post now.
And that's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion the go to erasable pen,
and The Kelly Clarkson Show,
wanna celebrate those creating fearlessly,
just like you ma'am.
So they're gonna give
you a thousand dollars.
How's that sound?
(audience cheers)
- Oh my God! Thank you!
- [Kelly] I love that reaction!